exhaustos y deshidratados más de 50
refugiados rojillas se encuentran
varados en una playa de acé Indonesia
después de que el bote de madera en el
que viajaban tuviera problemas con su
motor somos refugiados rojillas vivimos
en bangladesh Y vinimos aquí desde
bangladesh la mayoría son hombres
procedentes de los afinados campamentos
en bangladesh que arriesgan su vida en
costosos y peligrosos viajes en
precarias embarcaciones como intento
desesperado por alcanzar países como
Malasia o Indonesia con el fin de
trabajar y encontrar una vida más digna
pese a enfrentarse a las detenciones
de todos ellos tres están en estado
grave pero la mayoría sufrió
deshidratación por eso son bastante
débiles algunos otros experimentan
dolores abdominales pero en general la
mayoría están deshidratados
las autoridades indonesias creen que hay
más embarcaciones a la deriva Y es que
es el tercer barco de refugiados que
llegan los últimos meses
no podemos confirmarlo ya que solo
pudimos Tomar nota de los que ya están
aquí Pero algunas personas lo dijeron
según su testimonio llevaban un mes a la
deriva en el mar eran de mi alma
los organismos humanitarios alertaron la
semana pasada de una embarcación con
unas 190 personas mujeres hombres y
niños a la deriva en el mar de andamán Y
es que según acnur desde finales de
noviembre el reportes de más de una
docena de refugiados muer